our bodies are great at losing heat and
our clothes are great at keeping heat in
now researchers have made a textile that for the first time keeps skin cool
using already existing materials
the history of clothing technology has been all about  keeping us warm
fur, feathers, and wool all hold pockets of warm air next to the skin
cooling is a bigger challenge
high-tech wicking technology does cool you
but only once you start sweating
this new approach is passive
no pumps or fans needed and it doesn't make
you wait for the sweat to begin working
bodies lose heat through infrared or
thermal radiation
these waves are usually blocked or reflected by clothes
some materials like plastic film can let
these waves through
the catch?
they also let in visible light
clearly not suitable for clothing
but using the common plastic polyethylene
engineers may have figured out a way to make it work
they found that plastic with certain
size pores allows thermal radiation to pass through
but the pores scatter visible light
giving the material a solid white appearance
the textile is more efficient
at radiating heat than cotton
in fact it can keep fake skin about 2.7
degrees cooler in lab tests
This might seem like a small amount but little
numbers can make a big difference only a
few degrees change in a building's
temperature for example can save
forty-five percent of the energy needed
for cooling
so now you can lose the heat without losing your shirt